beyond will too so my pick for today
we're looking at concerns about
returning to the office during this
pandemic according to linkedin
more than two-thirds of working
professionals say their workplaces
are now open nearly one-third say they
are required to return
but a majority 57 percent say they are
not comfortable doing so well we spoke
to a fitness instructor a teacher and a
former corporate pr manager
who shared their concerns about going
back to their workplaces
i'm a fitness professional when gyms
opened back up i had some concerns about
my health and safety we were expected to
return to work during covet for 75
of our wages and it felt like a real
devaluing of life
my feeling in going back to the
classroom is nervousness
i have three children my position was
eliminated in my corporate job
that represented a significant portion
of our family income
and our health care the scary thought
occurred to me
of what happens if we go back in person
and one of my students get sick
and maybe even dies am i
prepared to handle something like that
no
with knowing that school is going to be
virtual and i have a special needs
learner
it makes it very difficult for me to go
look for another full-time position
not knowing what the company's policies
will be covet has
made just living really anxiety-inducing
in our new normal series we're looking
at how
the coronavirus is changing our lives
every day
and how we can reduce anxiety about
going back to the workplace well we're
joined by linkedin editor at large
caroline
fairchild she joins us from her home in
brooklyn good morning to you
you know one of the first questions i
have is what assurances do
employees need to feel safe as they get
ready to return back to work
what assurances can the companies give
the employees
sure we're hearing through this survey
that we did of workers across the
country that employees are really
looking for their employers to create
coveted 19 specific policies to make
sure that a return to work is safe
a vast majority of employers are
requiring that their workers wear a mask
all day in the office
many are banning in-person meetings and
there's also staggered start so you
might not get to the office at the same
time as your colleagues
all of these are a way to make sure that
as offices are reopening workers are
feeling safe we're seeing a lot of
stress and anxiety right now as workers
are asked to return to work you spoke
with lots of workers across industries
and
employers are having to really think
about how to make sure that workers feel
safe and can
continue to be productive in the office
aside from just wearing the mask which
even our
our crew here they're all wearing masks
we make sure that we're maintaining
social distancing
what are some of the specific concerns
you're hearing though from parents
parents are telling us since the
beginning of this pandemic that working
productively from home has been a huge
challenge
over a third of the workers that we
surveyed in a recent survey told us that
they haven't felt productive at home
while balancing child care but
the rub is there is that a return to
office may not solve some of these
problems
over 30 percent of working parents told
us that if they had to return to the
office tomorrow they wouldn't have child
care options available
and get this 60 of workers are saying
that their employers are not allowing
them to make accommodations in their
schedule to
make up for the fact that schools may
not reopen and that they don't have
child care options available so this is
a big concern
i put a post on linkedin last week and
within an hour heard from
hundreds of working parents like some of
those that you spoke with and they're
just saying that there's so much stress
and anxiety they don't know what to do
and so they're having to have critical
conversations with their manager
about really what is next and how they
can continue to be productive during
this new normal
what does the data reveal about women in
particular and balancing
work and child care at the same time
millennial women have been
disproportionately affected by this
crisis we know this by looking at
linkedin data and looking at hiring data
as well as
who's applying for jobs right now so if
you think of millennial women these are
the women
that are most likely to have young kids
at home right now and they're getting
hired at a slower rate than their male
peers right now which is concerning
particularly in male dominant industries
like tech finance
media these are industries that were
struggling with hiring women before and
now they're hiring even fewer during
this pandemic
and we're also seeing millennial women
apply to jobs at a slower rate and that
probably has a lot to do with the fact
that
as one working mother wrote on linkedin
she's the default parent right now
through this pandemic so if she's
working and her husband's working she's
taking on
a vast majority of the child care needs
and if employers don't figure out how to
make accommodations for working parents
right now
it's going to have a long-term impact on
all of their careers and you have people
also on the other side that are not as
fearful
and eager to go back to work what are
you hearing from from those
people sure so we've looked at data
across
industries and construction workers are
actually funny enough
they're excited about the prospect of
returning to work and that probably has
a lot to do with the fact there are lots
of safety procedures
on job sites already to make sure that
social distance is maintained and
workers are safe
retail workers as you can imagine
they're the most hesitant right now to
return to work because of all the touch
points with customers
and we're seeing a lot of office jobs
they're switching a lot of what they're
doing to remote work
telehealth is we're switching a lot to
remote right now as well as a lot of
administrative roles
and learning education roles we're
seeing a lot of postings on linkedin for
e-learning
options so there's some adaptations that
are happening so that workers are
spending less time in the office and
then we're seeing across
industries a gamut of different feelings
about returning to work
and obviously people need money they
need to go back to work eventually
what do you tell the folks who are
really concerned about saying
something to their employee about their
concerns and maybe even fearful that
they could lose their job if they
complain or have
real concerns about returning
what i'd say to that employee is that
leaders really have to lead with empathy
right now the number one trait that we
see experts saying on linkedin that
managers and employers need to think
about right now is empathetic leadership
and that means
putting yourself in the shoes of your
employee if you think about it if you
have a worker who is anxious and nervous
about the prospect of returning
to work there's no way that they're
going to be productive so we're seeing a
lot of employers make accommodations
bring more flexibility to the job to
make sure that employers feel safe and
feel like they can be productive
and we're seeing just go to your manager
with a clear proposal if they're anxious
about the fact that your team is going
to be the office and you're going to
continue to work from home
address that head on and say i'll do
more video calls i'll send an email at
the end of the day letting you know
what i've been doing i'll give you
access to my calendar there are ways
that in this new normal we can continue
to work from hope and do so productively
well we've made it work this long so
good luck to everyone out there trying
to make it work
carolyn fairchild thank you so much for
helping us understand it all